so it's five o'clock in York City and
I'm about to catch a cab so five miles
uptown
[Music]
[Music]
so it just took me 40 minutes to go
about 4.5 miles which is pretty typical
for a New York City rush hour despite a
speed limit of 25 miles per hour the
average car moving through Manhattan is
driving at just 7 miles per hour down
from 9 miles per hour in 2010 and if
you're in Midtown it's even worse with
cars moving around 5 miles per hour
but it's not just New York City traffic
in cities like LA is so bad drivers
could be locked in gridlock for hours of
course this sucks for drivers but it
also makes activities like biking or
walking less safe because cyclists and
pedestrians have to weave through an
obstacle course of cars not to mention
the estimated twenty billion dollars
lost in revenue due to time wasted
sitting in traffic now there might be a
solution but if you commute by car you
are probably not gonna like it
it's called congestion pricing and it
means charging drivers for using the
road congestion pricing is an idea whose
time has come
and I believe this is the year to
actually get it done
New York's plan is still in the works
and it probably won't be enacted until
2020 but the end game is to reduce
congestion by discouraging people from
driving if they have other options like
biking or taking a train or walking and
to fund public transit at the same time
it's not a groundbreaking idea a
congestion pricing is already old news
in cities around the world
London enacted a similar policy in 2003
this is a necessary step to us to
reclaim some of this space ice County
given to my choice vehicles without
ending up grizzle
Nicole batts uber researches urban
infrastructure and policy at the
University of Cambridge and according to
her the system is pretty simple when
drivers entered the central London
congestion zone between 7 a.m. and 6
p.m. they're charged 11 pounds 50 pence
about 15 US dollars New York City's plan
will be similar when drivers enter
Midtown or lower Manhattan they'll face
a fate those cameras all around the
roads area plates of the car or the
vehicle entering the zone London has a
few exemptions in place like for people
who live inside the congestion zone or
vehicles with nine or more seats and New
York City will likely do that too and
the system works so since it was
introduced we've seen that private
vehicles in between the zone have gone
down by 40 percent overall vehicle
traffic has gone down by 25 percent
cycling overall has increased 66 percent
since the charge was instituted and bus
ridership reached a 50-year high in 2011
and wait times for buses decreased 25
percent due to increased service on both
buses and the London Underground
so we now in comparison stem have much
higher frequencies of ireland's and
underground services we can get more
people more capacity more people into
our trains because we have newer trains
and like Nicole said congestion pricing
isn't just about removing cars from
specific zones it's about reclaiming a
space for the public pit row Trafalgar
Square but designed for cars an idea
that was very much a reality before
congestion pricing you would basically
have a bus driving white posture nose of
the National Gallery reclaiming that
section of road made the square safer
and opened it to more public events no
one could imagine going back to what it
was before when having these cars and
buses in posture London's plan is widely
embraced today but it was met with
resistance at first with opponents
arguing that congestion pricing could
cut people off from health care shopping
Plus people have to trust that the
government would work efficiently and
make significant improvements to their
public transit system but within a year
London's congestion charging had
majority support as New York's plan is
being finalized similar resistance is
cropping up which isn't too surprising
after all it's the first US city to
implement this type of congestion
pricing and no one wants to pay for
something they've gotten for free for so
long but the plan could generate up to a
billion dollars for public transit a
system that most agreed desperately
needs repair and the city estimates it
will reduce congestion by 8 to 13
percent and increased speeds by up to 9%
making a ride through Midtown a lot
easier so like other cities where
congestion pricing has been successful
it's likely that people will end up
accepting it when we think of all roads
in particular in cities are so public
good as public space then if you're
taking a little bit you should probably
be paying for that privilege if you
start to think about how everyone gets
around the city
charging cars begins to make a lot more
sense you pay for parking pay for the
subway pay to take a trainer bus so why
wouldn't we pay for a city road thanks
for watching if you haven't already
heard we've launched a paid membership
program called the Vox video lab right
here on YouTube
for a monthly fee subscribers get access
to tons of exclusive content and
becoming a member is the best way to
support our journalism so if you want to
join head over to voxcom slash join and
we'll see you there